bonjour à tous je commence cet épisode
par une petite introduction pour
remettre un petit peu les choses en
place la vidéo vous vous apprêtez à
regarder est un épisode de sociologique
classique dans la mesure où il a une
unité et il peut se regarder de façon
complètement indépendante des autres
cela dit il fait quand même directement
suite à l'épisode de sociaux classiques
que j'avais fait sur norbert elias et je
vous invite d'abord à aller voir cette
vidéo pour comprendre la totalité des
références théoriques que je vais faire
dans cet épisode
à ce propos j'en profite pour parler un
petit peu de l'actualité de la chaîne
d'abord j'ai un nouveau micro qu'il est
peu mais plus sérieusement je me suis
aperçu que la plupart de mes abonnés
n'était en fait pas au courant quand je
sortait une nouvelle vidéo et c'est
quand même pas si souvent donc c'est
dommage
du coup si ce n'est pas déjà fait je
vous invite à cliquer sur la petite
cloche à côté du bouton abonnés ce qui
vous permettra de recevoir une
notification contient une nouvelle vidéo
sur la chaîne et pour le coup si une
chose est sûr c'est qu'avec mon rythme
de publication je ne vais pas vous flou
des votre fil d'actualité si vous voulez
être au courant de ce qui se passe
n'hésitez pas aussi à rejoindre la page
facebook sur laquelle j'essaye de mettre
un petit peu d'actualité sur la chaîne
et la sociologie en général allez viens
regarde comme on est bien on est déjà 42
sur ce je vous souhaite un bon épisode à
tous et pour qu'on parte tous du même
pied commençons par un petit résumé des
épisodes précédents
elias est un sociologue allemand
découvert sur le tard est principalement
connu pour sa thèse du processus de
civilisation
en étudiant les sociétés occidentales il
étudie en particulier le long processus
qui se caractérise à la fois par une
baisse générale de la violence dans la
société et par le développement dans
pouvoir centralisé capable de faire
appliquer des lois
cette judiciarisation et cette
normalisation des rapports sociaux se
fait donc voir par la suite dans les
individus qui apprennent par des
nouvelles règles de convenance à
réprimer leurs pulsions et à faire
preuve justement de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la civilité et que nous
paraît naturel mais dont les normes nous
ont construite petit à petit au cours de
longs siècles
tout au long de son analyse il montre
des exemples concrets de ce phénomène
dans la vie des gens qui visent souvent
à mettre à distance le caractère brut et
animale des individus comme le fait
d'utiliser une fourchette là où ce
n'était pas nécessairement la norme
autrefois où le fait que le crachat est
désormais considéré comme un outrage
là où il était auparavant vu comme une
pratique saine
mais aussi par le développement de
nouveaux comportements comme la pudeur
qui n'était absolument pas de mise dans
l'antiquité ou au moyen âge et qui se
répand de plus en plus jusqu'à l'arrivée
et à la généralisation 20e siècle du
beau du grand du mighty bidet et plus
généralement des toilettes et de la
salle de bains qu'on peut verrouiller de
l'intérieur privatisant ainsi des gestes
qui était auparavant public
il note également des différences dans
les manières d'être là où la force
physique pouvaient auparavant être
valorisé la norme bascule peu à peu vers
une valorisation du contrôle de
l'indifférence et de l'importance
nouvelle donnée à la parole et à langage
distinguer et raffinée elias a donc
étudié ce processus de civilisation tout
au long de sa vie et selon plusieurs
dimensions et plusieurs objets d'étude
ce que nous allons étudier aujourd'hui
et un de ses terrains d'observation dans
le monde du sport avec un ouvrage tardif
coécrit avec l'anglais eric dunning et
publié en france en 1994 sous le titre
sport et civilisations une violence
maîtrisée
l'édition originale avait été publié en
anglais en 1984 sous le titre qwest par
ex iceman ce sport dont l'égérie de
stephen king process ans dans ce livre
en fait il se propose simplement de
vérifier sa théorie un du processus de
civilisation
mais en regardant l'évolution des sports
à travers l'histoire et ce qui va
essayer de montrer c'est que voilà les
sports actuels sont tendanciellement
moins violent et font preuve de plus de
contrôles que les sports du passé mais
va aussi s'interroger plus largement sur
la fonction du sport dans la société
et voilà ce que ça met en évidence sur
lui sa théorie de
l'évolution des civilisations
[Musique]
alors d'abord ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que le sport il a beaucoup changé depuis
le moyen âge déjà il ya de plus en plus
de gens qui commencent à le pratiquer et
ça se développe à mal récemment avec le
développement de ce qu'on a appelé la
société de loisirs c'est la société dans
laquelle on vit aujourd'hui une société
dans laquelle on a de plus en plus de
temps libre
et oui puisque avec les 35 heures
légales les congés payés
on a mécaniquement plus de temps pour
faire du sport
alors que bon au moyen âge raconte on
travaille dans les champs du lever au
coucher du soleil
on n'a pas vraiment le temps à côté pour
faire du sport et de l'activité physique
6 1 mais pas du sport alors pourquoi je
distingue activité physique et sport
c'est parce qu'il faut bien voir que ces
deux choses complètement différentes 1
je vous rappelle que les échecs c'est un
spa et même plus récemment on a même le
développement du dysport qui en bonne
voie pour obtenir la même qualification
du coup en fait la définition du sport
c'est pas dans l'activité physique ça va
plus être le fait qu'il ya des règles
une compétition en fait c'est
l'organisation sociale qui va y avoir
autour de la pratique qui va compter je
vais reprendre la définition de
wikipédia pour être sur le sport c'est
un ensemble d'exercices physiques ou
mentaux se pratiquant sous forme de jeux
individuels ou collectifs pouvant donner
lieu à des compétitions
voilà un nom qu'on voit un des éléments
importants c'est que le juge le sport ça
se pratique un peu sous forme de jeu et
pour qu'on puisse avoir des jeux il faut
qu'il y ait des règles donc déjà pour
que le sport puisse apparaître il faut
qu'on vive dans une société suffisamment
pacifié pour qu'on puisse mettre en
place des règles communes et qu'elles
soient respectées par tous les
participants
est ce que vont essayer de montrer elias
et downing c'est que dans l'histoire
quand on met un place un sport quand on
crée un sport il va souvent avoir une
fonction un peu d'exutoire ça veut dire
que ça va être une façon d'expulser un
petit peu ses pulsions mais d'une façon
un petit peu plus cadré que simplement
se foutent sur la gueule
enfin ça on verra ça dépend un peu de
sport et pour faire une petite
références geek parce que je peux pas
m'en empêcher
je vais vous parler un petit peu de la
saga eragon donc si pour une raison ou
pour une autre vous n'avez pas lu les
eragon et vous ne voulez pas que je vous
révèle des éléments de la faim sauter
directement ce time code
sinon on est parti alors pour être sûr
qu'on parte bien tous sur la même base
eragon c'est une série de quatre livres
écrits par l'auteur américain
christopher paolini alors l'auteur avait
15 ans quand il a commencé à écrire son
histoire
et si c'est effectivement une saga
grandement orienté jeunesse l'histoire
est tout de même intéressante et même si
la trame n'est pas d'une originalité
folle
tout cela reste plaisant et divertissant
avec même quelques très bons passages
ce sont des livres de fantasy où l'on
sent venir de loin les inspirations du
jeune auteur on se trouve dans un monde
fictif qui s'appelle al agha esia où
l'on suit les aventures du jeune eragon
non pas aragorn et eragon oui voilà et
qui après avoir trouvé un oeuf de dragon
devient un nouveau dragonnier une
personne qui partage sa vie et ses
pensées avec un dragon
mais il est le tout dernier car tous ses
semblables ont été trucider par le
méchant roi galbatorix à la mort de son
oncle il se fera entraînée par brom le
compteur du village qui se révèlera être
lui-même un ancien dragonnier non jacky
tu m'as pas mais les bonnes
illustrations là bas maintenant on s'en
fout pas après les gens ils vont pas
comprendre vraiment aller les images du
bouzin la voilà donc après la mort de
son oncle il se fera entraînée par brom
le compteur du village qui se révèlera
être lui même un ancien dragonnier une
petite parenthèse au passage parce que
je sais que j'utilise des images du film
pour illustrer mes propos mais on est
bien d'accord que ce sont des livres que
je parle et que le film eragon c'est une
sombre bouse lacunaire qui rend à peu
près autant hommage au matériau
d'origine que tolkien accorder
d'importance aux personnages féminins en
parlant de tolkien justement l'univers
de paolini est très clairement inspiré
du seigneur des anneaux
ce monde nous présente en effet
plusieurs races qui ont chacune leur
langue leur culture
il y a les humains les dragons des elfes
des nains des heures non pas des orques
justement parce que ici on les appelle
des mesures galles est justement ce sont
eux qui vont nous intéresser ici
et au passage les organes c'est
précisément un des nombreux points sur
lequel le film s'est méchamment marc
avait la gueule dans le travail
d'adaptation dans le livre les organes
sont des êtres puissant fiers guerriers
avec des griffes à la place des ongles
des cornes de taureau au dessus des
oreilles
il mesure entre 1 m 80 pour les plus
petits et 2 mètres 70
pour les plus grands ils parlent une
langue froide et gutturale ils n'ont pas
la finesse vu la rapidité des elfes
mais ils font preuve d'une force
redoutable et sont des combattants
féroces et dans le film on a eu droit ça
j'ai de la peinture sur les yeux donc je
suis méchant et j'en veux vraiment au
film d'avoir raté les organes parce que
je suis persuadé qu'ils sont l'une des
vraiment bonne chose qu'on trouve dans
les livres de paolini dans le premier
livre les ures galfond figure
d'antagonistes principaux un peu comme
les orques du seigneur des anneaux pour
le coup on sont les forces armées du
sage noir du rose à qui fait un peu
office de saroumane de service mais
lorsque ce dernier se prend un grosse
bulle à la fin de la bataille son
emprise sur les organes se relâchent et
on apprend en fait que dura les
contrôler complètement et avait ainsi
réuni autour de lui cinq clans ennemis
dur galles qui n'auraient jamais pu
oeuvrer ensemble s'ils n'avaient été
sous l'emprise du sortilège
par conséquent quand le sortilège se
brisent les ures galles commencent à se
[ __ ] allègrement sur la gueule et
oublie complètement nos personnages qui
s'en sortent tranquillement mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que notre vision à
leur sujet va évoluer un peu tout au
long de l'histoire
alors qu'au début on les personnes
vraiment comme des buts sanguinaire sans
cerveau qui aime juste taper sur la
gueule et se faire la guerre on va
s'apercevoir qu'en fait ils ont vraiment
une culture complexe avec des rites des
traditions et qu'en fait c'est pas aussi
manichéen que les orques du seigneur des
anneaux par exemple et de fait c'est une
race ancienne qui si elle aime se battre
c'est parce qu'elles placent l'honneur
et les valeurs guerrières comme les
toutes premières de l'organisation
sociale et oui toute ressemblance avec
des cultures existantes ou ayant existé
serait totalement fortuite mais les
organes considère la violence comme
nécessaires pour devenir un homme
ton plus violent que coûte
plutôt comme un homme comme enfin noms
communs comme un mur galles plutôt du
coup oui bon bah qu'est ce qu'il ya
jaequi pourquoi tu regardes comme ça bon
bah enchaîne on voit même quelques chocs
culturels se profilait principalement
dans le dernier livre pour vaincre son
ennemi
eragon qui est maintenant à moitié
humain à moitié elf me demandez pas
pourquoi je ne vais pas m'étendre sur
les fantasmes intéresse pièces d'un
petit geek de californie rassemble une
armée où il cherche à faire coexister
toutes les races qui finalement ont tout
à y gagner à faire tomber galbatorix on
y retrouve donc des humains des elfes
des nains et des organes et on assiste à
quelques scènes intéressantes quand
l'auteur nous montre des interactions
entre tout ce beau monde qui laisse
paraître des écarts culturels énormes
qui sont intéressantes à explorer en
particulier ce héros rend le frère
deragon qui va nous intéresser ici parce
que au fil des livres son personnage
s'est développé et il a levé locke et
depuis qu'il a choisi le marteau comme
arme de prédilection dans le premier
bouquin il est maintenant devenu une
espèce de capitaine ammer de service
bon pas ce captain gamin outre ses
capacités de combattants et s'est
également révélée être un incroyable
meneur d'hommes et c'est donc tout
naturellement qu'on lui confie la
commande de régiment au sein de l'armée
régiment au sein desquels se trouvent
des organes et justement c'est là où ça
coince
parce que dans leur culture les organes
ne peuvent pas supporter le déshonneur
de suivre les ordres d'un être qu'il
juge inférieur
mais plutôt que de réprimer tout ça en
demandant à son frère de tout cramer
dragonne style haut rang qui commence à
aborder la culture des organes comme un
fieffé anthropologue structuraliste
comprend qu'il doit se faire accepter
selon leurs critères pour que ça marche
il défie donc en combat singulier l'un
des meneurs et après lui avoir bien
poutre et la gueule à mains nues
oui moi aussi je trouve ça un peu
capilotracté il se fait finalement
accepté des organes sans autre
ronchonnements ce qui permet donc de
créer une armée qui tient à peu près la
route pour aller mener la grande
bataille contre les forces du mal
on peut le dire ça ce n'est pas copé
rites et les forces du mal si et du coup
un problème se pose à la fin du livre
quand le méchant est battu parce que à
la fin du livre le méchant est battu je
vous avais dit qu'elle du spoil et du
coup faire la guerre c'est un peu le
mode normal d'organisation de la société
que ce soit entre eux 20 entre
différents clans aux différentes tribus
ou contre d'autres races da la gamme
diam et de fait il faut qu'ils aient de
la guerre quoi et ça ça a posé un
problème à nos héros et oui parce que
nos héros ce qu'ils veulent c'est que le
nouveau monde qui vont réussir à
construire il soit plutôt basée sur la
paix sur le respect entre tous les
peuples et à le dilemme il intéressant
parce que ce qu'on a découvert au fil de
l'histoire c'est que les organes c'est
pas juste des êtres sanguinaires et son
cerveau c'est pas juste des bêtes
sauvages qui aiment le sang et la mort
c'est au contraire à une vraie société
organisée avec des valeurs des
traditions anciennes et le personnage
principal il est plutôt dans le respect
de toutes les traditions de toutes les
valeurs du coup ce qu'il faut faire
c'est qu'il faut réussir à trouver une
façon que les eurent égalé puissent
conserver leur culture 1 basée sur la
force physique et sur l'honneur et en
même temps que l'on soit pas dans une
guerre perpétuelle est la solution qui
est trouvée c'est de mettre en place des
jeux olympiques et des tournois
qui auront la fonction qui avait
auparavant les guerres entre les
différentes tribus les différentes races
et les du coup là on voit clairement
dans eragon un exemple tout à fait
pertinent de la mise en place d'un sport
dans le but de faire réduire la violence
de la société et d'intérioriser un petit
peu les pulsions et d'agir du coup comme
une espèce d'exutoire de toutes les
pulsions incorporé et là on peut
clairement faire le parallèle avec nos
sociétés à nous parce que 1 les premiers
tournois de chevaliers qui ont été
organisées en europe
c'était pas aussi bien organisés plein
d'honneur et plein d'esprit sportif
commencent leur présente souvent dans
les films un nom dans les bureaux pour
le coup ben de la chaîne nota bene à
faire un épisode là dessus et comme il
le dit lui même
même si ces médias nous expose une
partie de la vérité
il convient de nuancer nos propos car
les tournois c'était avant tout du
bourrinage et oui effectivement dans les
premiers tournois qu'on appelle les
simbel
il y avait un niveau de violence assez
élevé et il n'était pas rare qu'il y ait
des morts mais n'est pas rare du tout
même
enfin à chaque fois on fait ça tout le
temps dans vers les mecs s'entraîner
avec des armes réelles
forcément il y avait du grabuge quoi et
on voit clairement dans ce type de sport
une dimension qui étaient là pour
canaliser la violence des gens pour le
coup ben fait lui même la remarque dans
sa vidéo la première version du site
bell avait pour but selon moi de
canaliser les excès de violence et la
folie des grandeurs des différents
protagonistes
c'est beaucoup plus tard que l'on a fini
par introduire des âmes plus émoussé
mettre plus de règle ça a d'ailleurs
tenté d'être interdite plusieurs fois
par l'église et par les institutions
le roi etc mais ça militants on
assistera progressivement à une
codification de ce sport les ornements
font leur apparition ont des corps et
ont peint les armes et une très grande
courtoisie est exigé entre les
participants du tournoi avant et après
match
alors si le sujet vous intéresse je vous
encourage très fortement à regarder le
reste de sa vidéo qui date de décembre
2014 où il passe en revue quatre sports
extrêmes
au fil de l'histoire et où on voit que
le sport aujourd'hui c'est quand même un
peu plus tranquille
et effectivement si le sport parents
étaient effectivement de canaliser la
violence ça restait quand même pas mal
bourrin quoi parce que oui y'a comme je
les lis a toujours eu des règles dans le
sport mais dans les premiers sports les
règles c'était quand même le strict
minimum
on peut voir l'exemple du pancrase 5e
développe peine dans sa vidéo qui est un
sport de lutte de l'antiquité romaine ou
là absolument tous les coups sont permis
1 enfin presque tous les coups seuls les
morsures ou l'arrachage des yeux étaient
interdits ob c'est bon alors si on n'a
pas le droit d'arracher les yeux de son
adversaire c'est que c'est tranquille ou
comme sport et encore une fois je vous
invite à regarder le reste de la vidéo
en regardant ça on constate que les
réglementations quand même pas mal bougé
dans le sport contemporain parce que je
suis pas en train de dire qu'il n'existe
pas des sports violents aujourd'hui par
exemple la mma mixed martial art ce mets
arts martiaux mélangés qui est je pense
l'un des sports les plus violents que
l'on s'habitue aujourd'hui mais
justement on s'est habitué à des
standards de sport qui ont été pas mal
pacifié depuis les origines parce que
justement je suis allé voir les règles
de la mma et dans la catégorie des coûts
qui sont interdits en fait on a pas mal
de coups interdits
on a le coup de pied ou de genoux pour
l'adversaire est déjà au sol les
morsures le tirage de cheveux les
griffures et même le crachat sur
l'adversaire comme quoi il ya vraiment
un truc sur le crachin mais figurez vous
qu'à aucun moment il ya écrit qu'on n'a
pas le droit d'arracher les yeux ton
adversaire
c'est fou ça quand même alors je le dis
en rigolant mais ça montre bien une
chose c'est que aujourd'hui on n'a plus
besoin d'écrire une telle règle ça
viendrait pas à l'idée à un opposant à
mma d'arracher les yeux de son
partenaire du coup il n'y a même pas
besoin d'écrire la règle parce qu'on vit
vraiment dans une société plus pacifié
et moins violentes
et ça ça se retrouve notamment dans les
règles
beaucoup plus strictes qui encadrent la
plupart de nos sports pour conclure le
travail des liasses et de nîmes dans le
monde du sport a été assez majeur parce
qu'il permet en réalité une meilleure
compréhension de la société dans son
ensemble
et comme ils le disent eux mêmes nous
étions très conscient que la
connaissance sur le sport était une
connaissance sur la société et il est
vrai que le sport peut être un angle
particulièrement pertinent pour observer
l'évolution de nos sociétés
elias s'arrête longuement sur la
coïncidence entre la jeunesse des sports
et l'établissement de régime
parlementaire comme ils l'observent
notamment dans l'angleterre du xviiie
siècle
ils soulignent bien sûr qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un lien causal c'est pas comme si
les stades de foot produisez des
parlementaires mais plutôt que le sport
et le parlement sont tout deux
caractéristiques du même changement dans
la structure du pouvoir et dans
l'habitude sociale des individus là où
son analyse est original c'est qu'il ne
fait donc pas du sport une forme de
résistance à la civilisation une espèce
d'archaïsme comme l'avait avancé le
sociologue thorstein veblen mais au
contraire une avancée dans le processus
de civilisation
puissent ils constituent une libération
contrôlée des pulsions pour aller plus
loin on peut en effet donner raison à
elias et remarqué que le sport bien loin
de se voir abandonnée par le processus
de civilisation ses routines is est au
coeur de nos pratiques quotidiennes
tout comme il s'est institutionnalisée
au niveau géopolitique dans la gestion
des relations internationales il n'ya
qu'à observer l'histoire pour voir que
s'imposer sur le plan sportif a toujours
été un moyen d'asseoir une certaine
forme de puissance sur la scène
géopolitique comme le disait george
orwell
le sport c'est la guerre mon les fusils
on peut par exemple noté les jeux
olympiques de 1952 qui voit la toute
première participation de l'urss aux jo
d'helsinki et qui participe à la mise en
place de la guerre froide car les deux
puissances urss et états unis remporte
50% des médailles
l'urss passant devant les etats unis en
1956 avec 37 médailles contre 32 et
confirmant les plans en 1960 avec 43
médailles contre 37
on peut d'ailleurs remarquer que même
dans le cinéma à les rapports
internationaux ont aussi pu être
transposée à travers les disciplines
sportives est le meilleur exemple de
cela et sans doute
le quelque peu nanardesque rocky iv qui
fait s'affronter le champion du monde de
boxe américain évidemment contre un
géant russe sans pitié et gonflé aux
anabolisants
ce film a reçu son lot de critiques et
pas moins de neuf nominations au razzie
awards
mais il reste le signe d'une époque et
je ne peux m'empêcher de le regarder
avec beaucoup de plaisir même le joli
discours rassembleur de roquier à la fin
qui est une parfaite illustration de ce
que je veux montrer sur le rôle du sport
dans les relations internationales
sur le ring y avait deux gars qui
s'entretuaient mais quand même c'est
mieux que 20 millions
bientôt mon jeu tandis que je suis là je
dois 7 millions en octobre alors oui ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est que si
moi j'ai changé bientôt vos jetons en
cache tétons jasmin c'est que vous avez
changé minutes tout le monde peut
arriver à changer hostel bombe ou [ __ ]
au seul parce que la russie allait plus
généralement on peut également voir que
le monde du sport est constamment
traversé par des sous texte politique
les hommes d'état sont souvent présents
lors des rencontres et ils connaissent
tous les noms des joueurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rencontre qui deviennent alors des
moments informels de renforcement de
certains liens entre les pays et l'on
sait que la possibilité d'être un pays
organisateur
que ce soit pour les grands événements
comme la coupe du monde ou les jeux
olympiques peut non seulement avoir de
grandes retombées économiques et
politiques mais peut aussi avoir des
conséquences sportives tant il est rare
que les pays accueillant ne passe pas
les qualifications pour ce qui est du
processus de civilisation et en
particulier dans le monde du football
le sociologue patrick mignon a montré
dans son ouvrage la passion du football
que ce sport permettait un usage règle
et de la violence qui a notamment permis
selon lui de réorienter la violence
spontanée l indiscipline des classes
dirigeantes anglaise lors de la
popularisation de ce sport dans les
années 1840 en particulier en retient
l'écriture en 1848 dé cambridge routes
ou des règles de cambridge qui sont
célèbres dans l'histoire du football car
elles décrivent entre autres choses les
conditions d'octroi des coups francs et
des touches
elles ont par la suite été complétée
dans les règles de 1863 qui sont la
principale source d'inspiration pour la
mise en place du football tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui un football qui est
encore aujourd'hui un formidable levier
d'intégration et de développement des
sociabilités en particulier dans les
clubs amateurs péri urbain où les autres
structures produisant du lien social se
sont peu à peu délité et il montre ainsi
que la création de clubs amateurs de
football a notamment été initiée par le
patronat des années 1930 avec des
formations créées par peugeot en france
où fiat en italie qui avait pour intérêt
d'encadrer les loisirs populaires et
accessoirement d'améliorer la santé
physique de la force de travail on voit
donc à quel point sport et civilisations
sont effectivement intimement entrelacés
et à quel point le travail des liasses
et de ning permet d analyse
intéressantes sur le processus de
civilisation
mais pour terminer sur la thèse des
liasses on peut tout de même relevé
quelques critiques à sa théorie
principale
la première est celle qui lui a souvent
été reproché étant bien sûr la violence
qui a été celle du 20è siècle et en
particulier l'allemagne nazie qu'il
serait trop facile de vouloir exclure de
notre construction sociétales comme si
ça n'avait été qu'un bref moment de
décivilisation au sein d'un processus
plus large
le deuxième reproche qui lui est souvent
faits concernent plus directement le
sport ait un rapport avec le
hooliganisme
la question étant que si le sport peut
avoir pour fonction
de participer au contrôle de la violence
au sein de la société et à
l'apprentissage de l'auto contrôle des
pulsions individuel comment interpréter
le fait qu'il puisse être le théâtre de
l'eau liga nisme et cette question là
nous permet en fait de toucher le
problème plus profond dans le travail
des liasses et que certains d'entre vous
n'ont pas manqué de noter dans ma
dernière vidéo qui tient en fait dans la
définition qu'il fait de la violence il
utilise en fait une vision très
restreinte de la violence la violence
physique qu'il qualifie d' agressivité
ou de pulsions mais qui ne permet pas de
rendre compte de la dynamique de son
apparition du fait qu'ils ne
s'intéressent qu'au résultat final qui
est la violence physique
il passe ainsi sous silence les autres
formes de violence verbale social fait
d'incivilité ou de petites infractions
qui peuvent ainsi avoir des effet de
spirale qui débouche ainsi sur une
violence physique mais qui n'est donc
que l'aboutissement d'un long processus
d'interaction sociale subtil et complexe
malgré ses limites toutes ses analyses
restent néanmoins intéressante et
permettent à mon sens une meilleure
compréhension de notre société et je
laisse des sources dans la description
pour ceux qui souhaiteraient aller plus
loin cet épisode de sociologique est
maintenant terminée je vous invite à
mettre un pouce vers le haut et à
partager la vidéo si elle vous a plu
vous pouvez toujours rejoindre la page
facebook pour avoir des actualités sur
la chaîne et moi je me fais des bisous
et je vous dis à la prochaine
[Musique]
à